i was asked a question recently about
how to get along with anyone and i guess
the question to you is do you get along
with everybody you
do you get along with everyone some
tells me you don't get along with
everybody
let's unpack this and see what this
really means to get along with anyone
can somebody really get along
with everybody the answer is both yes
and it is no
let's first talk about one side of it so
how do some people get along with
everyone well
the relationships always surface level
never goes deeper
the relationship is always very aloof
the relationship is always how you doing
good good boom done they're not going
anything deeper like how you doing
it's very simple right where it goes to
the relationship is very safe
okay if you keep it like that you're
typically going to get along with most
people there's not really deep
relationships
but you get along with most people right
so you kind of keep that distance to
everybody
now the reason why not everybody gets
along with everybody is because the
moment
if you think about who you don't get
along with the most all the time
you probably have a sibling on that list
okay you could have a spouse on that
list
you could have a boyfriend girlfriend or
a parent or a friend that is a best
friend maybe even a co-worker
you know what all those six have in
common you've spent the most time with
them
it's typically what happens on who you
get along with the most and who you
don't get along with
sometimes it's safer to not get too
close to people because it's always safe
this is why some people are afraid of
real serious relationships because what
if i get too deep
and this relationship doesn't work yet
this marriage doesn't work out what if
this partnership doesn't work out
what if this hire doesn't work out so
it's always safe you're not getting
rejected you're not having to reject
so it's always that there's people that
like to break up first all the time
because they're afraid of getting close
to that movie
years ago i watched with uh the girl
from runaway bride i don't know what her
name is runaway bride what is her name
from runway julia roberts right runway
bride
where she was always right before
getting married boom she would run away
she would run away she never wanted to
get too close
because what if it doesn't work out so
now let's set that part aside
here's the other part about get along
with everyone say you start having a
conversation with somebody and it's a
stranger
first five minutes you get along it's
going great all of a sudden five minutes
later the topic is
so tell me what you think about biden
versus trump
and he said well i got to tell you i
just think biden's nicer
and i think biden's more uh kind and
he's going to be the person but i think
trump is just not a person i support at
all
and all of a sudden you see the person
going like this okay
you have officially gotten somebody to
not like you
okay now you say so tell me what do you
think about
the presidency who are you who you're
leaning towards who do you think is
going to win oh i think it's going to be
trump trump's a great leader
you know trump's getting things done you
know i like the fact that he built the
wall
you like the fact that he built the
moment you say that one of three things
is going to happen with that person
either the person is going to agree with
you which they're going to like you
either the person could care less
because they don't like politics why the
person is going to say
i can't believe you said that but one of
those three is going to happen there's a
33 percent chance
that one of these things is going to
happen so you're taking a risk meaning
in the world when you make when you take
a stand
you cannot take a stand hoping everybody
likes you
you cannot you cannot take a stand
thinking everyone's going to say you're
so amazing
if you see you like the lakers the
celtics fans are going to hate you
if you say you like the patriots you
know the brady fans that are at tampa
bay right now are going to dislike you
but whatever it is there's a stand if
you say politically
or spiritually you believe in god the
atheists are going to say what do you
mean you believe in god
if you say you believe in a certain
denomination the other denomination is
going to say how could you think about
that there's no one
have you read this book have you there's
always something there so
this having said this putting that aside
knowing that
if you ever open your mouth and decide
to have a deeper relationship with
somebody
there's eventually going to be
differences okay so now
many people stop right here and they say
if you don't like me you don't like me
that's your problem
that is your problem it's not my problem
if you don't like me okay
fine let's say that's a mindset but you
got to go deeper than that here's the
other deeper part of it
see i don't think the question is
whether you can get along with anyone
i think in life there's a reason why the
book how to win friends and influence
people that sold 40 million copies
by dale carnegie and this was the first
book i ever read
how to win friends and influence people
recommended to me by my sister when i
got out of the military
and i'd never finished a book in my life
how to win friends and influence people
talks about smile talks about find a way
to be agreeable talks about all this
other stuff
about dealing with people right listen
to them look at them all these things
on how to deal with people okay i
remember one time
i hired somebody and then we went out to
dinner
with a few friends and this person was
there and she brought a friend
and she brought a friend and i have not
said a single word
from the moment her friend sat there she
went like this
okay i have not even spoken to this
woman
i i don't have a social media presence
at this time we're talking o5
i don't have any social i don't have a
single video on facebook youtube
i'm not even on social media i the only
thing i have in all five
is a blackberry i'm not on myspace i'm
not on friendster i'm not on ao i'm not
on nothing
she comes in and she has an attitude
like this looking at me okay
and her my friend here she notices like
wow my friend really doesn't like this
how come she doesn't like you so we had
dinner finished got in with to talk a
lot she's giving me a
very cold attitude and then i leave she
leaves
i have no idea what happened she calls
me afterwards she says
um pat i wanted to bring something up
because it was kind of weird i said
what's that
says my friend really didn't like you
and it wasn't you
so then what is it she just said you're
reminded of her ex-husband
and the moment you walked and the way
you walked the way you did everything
she said you remind her of ex-husband
she said she believes you're this you're
this you're not like
i didn't even talk to this person okay
what does this mean
there's nothing i can do with a person
like that when a person looks at you and
says
i don't like you because you look like
xyz you remind me of xyz
you can't win those people so now let's
unpack this audience in three different
groups
there are those people that no matter
what you do
they are not going to get along with you
let's set that group aside
there are those people in your life that
you just mesh that you're going to get
along with
very simple you just you ever meet
somebody like oh my gosh i feel like
i've known this person for years
why is that there's that group this
isn't about this group
it isn't about this group it is the
group in the middle
that you can do something to get him to
not like you
and you can do something to get them to
like you where you can get along with
them
what is that that's the area where you
can improve in
because if the first mindset was if you
don't like me that's your problem i
don't care
i'm going to go my own way fine but
that's not highest level of thinking
that's surface level thinking even if
you go from that right what do you mean
if they don't like me they don't
you get all these motivational speakers
out they say if you don't like me that's
your problem i want to be like this
because it's me and i'm being
transparent and i'm being
authentic i get it but it does mean you
can't find you
find a way to change your approach maybe
maybe your approach is all about you
i was having dinner with one of our guys
the other day and i never forget what
this guy said
this guy said to one of our guys that
was sitting there says you know
this guy's like well you know what you
know
my wife always says good things about me
and i love it you know his wife is
sitting there saying oh my gosh you're
so amazing you're so this year so that
and one guy says you know what can i do
my girlfriend never says anything good
about me
and the one guy just flat out said well
the reason why she says nothing good
about you is because
every time we're around you all you do
is brag about yourself
so that's why she doesn't brag about you
because you brag about yourself so much
what she's like constantly hearing you
telling everybody how amazing you are
it's draining you always talk about your
perfections
you don't talk about your mistakes it's
draining how many things you do
wrong you do right people don't want to
be around that right so
that isn't a way of getting somebody to
get along with you
you you being willing to be a little bit
self-deprecation you ain't perfect you
ain't this always talking about what you
did right what you did right what you
did right the audience might be like
oh my gosh if i have to listen to this
perfect guy again because no one relates
to perfection i went to 26
churches before i finally committed to
one you know what
every church i went to the message was
you know
you're going to hell and this is god
this and you got to be this and you got
to be that
judgment judgment judgment judgment i'm
like i'm good
i don't want to belong to a church
that's filled with perfect people i want
to belong to a church that's filled with
imperfect people that have made mistakes
like me then i found a place
then the guy at the top says i've made
mistakes on this i'm like you know what
i relate
then i stuck around then i was there for
a long time because
we relate to people that have also made
mistakes that are not perfect
the moment somebody wins and they get on
their high horse no one wants to be
around somebody that gets on a high
horse
and no one cares how many millions of
dollars you got how many billions of
dollars you got what kind of a car you
drive how ridiculous of a six-pack you
got
how big your house is if you don't sit
there and listen to it i was at an event
and i laid this just
a couple days ago we were in two events
okay and this morning on a conference
calls
we're talking about a bunch of different
people and how do you build relation
with this and how do you build a
relationship with that
and i enjoy people i like sitting there
listening to people
because it reminds me the flaws i had
and i how i adjusted and i improved
what i did to my life right at one of
the events i stayed for three four hours
just talking to people
getting to know this person's story that
person's story this person's from
ebola you know in south africa
which is outside of la lagos and this
person is from
haiti and that person's from you know
japan and this person's from
sakatecas and that person's from durango
and this person's from michoacan and
that person's from san salvador
and this person is from tikala all of
these conversations with all these
people and the stories
so this is fascinating to learn about
people right
and while you're going through it what
people want to hear from me is
before i became who i am today god knows
how many mistakes i made god knows how
many mistakes i made
but then you listen you're like well let
me tell you what i did right and what i
did this what mistakes did you make
there are ways to improve the way you
deal with people so let's get back to it
number one yes if you want to get along
with everyone you can keep a fake
surface relationship with everybody
and be very aloof and you're not going
to have a lot of conflicts with people
but you also won't have a lot of deep
relationships you will not have a lot of
deep relationships and
life life is about having a lot of deep
relationships so value but so great
i mean l.a we went to rafi's place i sat
down with my friends armond steve awful
you know adam's their teachers and we
had just three hours one like this
great conversation these are friends
you're still not talking about life
debate fight all this stuff
it was beautiful because there's deep
relationships that we have together we
don't get along on all topics we don't
agree all on topics
but we have a deep relationship together
you want deep relationships in life
so that's that side then in life you got
people that are not gonna get along with
you
people that are gonna get along with you
and people in the middle and what can
you do for your approach with people to
get better
this is why books like how to win
friends and influence people do so well
if you've never read the book how to win
friends
and influence people it's a good book
for you to read and by the way
there's a video i did many years ago i
think it's four years ago how to choose
your business partner if you've never
watched this video how to choose your
business partner
click over here to watch this video of
how to choose your business partner
because eventually
if you don't have one right now you're
eventually going to have one you want to
make sure you choose the right business
partner
and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel please do so have a great week
everybody take care bye